>> WE’RE DANGEROUSLY RELIANT IN
PARTICULAR ON CHILDREN FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF CRITICAL GOODS AND
THAT INCLUDES GOODS THAT I
OUTLINED, NEEDED TO FIGHT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THE ACCESS TO BEEF UP DEMAND
HURTS OUR ABILITY TO MITIGATE
THE WORST EFFECTS OF THIS VIRUS.
THE RESULT IS THE VIRUS COULD BE
MORE DAMAGING THAN IT NEEDED TO
BE.
>> SHANNON: NEW VIDEO TONIGHT
FROM WUHAN, CHINA, THE ORIGIN OF
COVID-19.
SUPER MARKETS AND PHARMACY ARE
REOPENING FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE THE CITY WAS SHUT DOWN IN
LATE JANUARY.
NOW THAT THE NEW PEOPLE INFECTED
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS IN CHINA IS
SLOWING, THE COUNTRY’S COMMUNIST
PARTY IS RATCHETING UP THREATS
AGAINST THE WEST.
WITH A PARTICULARLY NASTY
WARNING ABOUT ACCESS TO
LIFE-SAVING DRUGS AIMED AT THE
UNITED STATES.
AS REPORTED TONIGHT, IT’S NOT
THE ONLY CONFLICT BETWEEN
AMERICA AND CHINA OVER THE
VIRUS.
RICH?
>> GOOD EVENING, SHANNON.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SUMMONED
CHINA’S TOP DIPLOMAT TO THE
UNITED STATES AS OFFICIALS
EXCUSE THE CHINA GOVERNMENT OF
SPREADING CONSPIRACY THEORIES
ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS.
THIS MORNING, THE AMBASSADOR
REFUSED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM
US AS HE LEFT STATE DEPARTMENT
HEADQUARTERS.
EFFICIENCY
OFFICIALS HERE SAY THEY OBJECT
TO THE GLOBAL MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN ON THE CORONAVIRUS.
AMERICAN OFFICIALS HAVE POINTED
TO THIS TWEET FROM A SPOKESMAN,
"IT MIGHT BE U.S. ARMY WHO
BROUGHT THE EPIDEMIC TO WUHAN.
BE TRANSPARENT.
MAKE PUBLIC YOUR DATA.
USO OFFERS AN EXPLANATION."
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE U.S.
SOLDIERS VISITING WUHAN IN
OCTOBER CARRIED THE VIRUS.
A SENIOR STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL SAYS CHINA IS TRYING TO
DEFLECT CRITICISM FOR HIDING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS AT THE ONSET OF MASS
INFECTIONS IN WUHAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS THE
ACCUSATION DOES NOT REPRESENT
THE VIEWS OF CHINA’S LEADERSHIP.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP: I DID READ
ONE ARTICLE BUT I DON’T THINK
THAT ARTICLE WAS REPRESENTATIVE,
CERTAINLY NOT OF MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH PRESIDENT XI.
WE KNOW WHERE IT CAME FROM.
>> DISINFORMATION ABOUT THE
VIRUS REMAINS A CHALLENGE.
FOX NEWS OBTAINED A REPORT
SHOWING THAT TWO MILLION TWEETS
WORLDWIDE ACROSS SIX WEEKS
EARLIER THIS YEAR SPREAD
CORONAVIRUS CONSPIRACIES.
THE MOST PROLIFIC LIES, THAT THE
BILL THAT THE MELINDA GATES
FOUNDATION CREATED IT, AND IT
WAS MANUFACTURED AS A BIOLOGICAL
WEAPON.
THEY ARE WORKING TO COMBAT